12 uhr 30 geht's los die große mpk und
es hat sich ganz danach an dass wieder
alles recht kleinteilig wird wir wollen
mit unserem nächsten gast sprechen und
zwar mit doktorgrad gas er ist der
vorstandsvorsitzende der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft herr dr gass was
fordern sie ganz genau von den
ministerpräsidenten in wenigen stunden
wir fordern seit jetzt einer geraumen
zeit dass das rk ii und das
bundesgesundheitsministerium mehr
vorlegt als die inzidenz zur politischen
entscheidung über zukünftige maßnahmen
über gebote über verbote über
regulierungen weil wir der auffassung
sind und das teilen ja viele politiker
aber auch viele wissenschaftler dass die
inzidenz aus der vergangenheit nicht
mehr taugt um die zukunft zu erklären
durch impfquoten und durch veränderte
virus mutanten hat sich die situation
auch verändert und deswegen brauchen wir
mehr kennzahlen wir haben ein tableau
vorgeschlagen aus den themenfeldern
incident sprich infektions lage im
bereich der impfungen im dynamic
impfquote aber auch dann die
hospitalisierung also wer kommt
eigentlich ins krankenhaus und tauchen
dort auch möglicherweise mehr personen
auf die schon vollständig geimpft sind
daran könnte man erkennen wie gut der
impfschutz noch ist ob nachgelegt wird
muss ein ähnliches diese daten liegen
dem rkw vor und wir fordern auf dass
diese daten wirklich jetzt übersichtlich
täglich vorgestellt werden und dann für
ein gemeinsames und einheitliches
handeln verwendet werden herr gast die
neuen kennzahlen beziehungsweise diese
kennzahlen so zu definieren dass ist
eine sache die andere sache sind
lockerungen und davon steht in dem
papier relativ wenig ihre meinung dazu
sollte man jetzt weiter lockern und für
mehr normalität stehen
ich glaube wir müssen uns immer vor
augen halten all das was hier angeboten
und verboten spricht also auch an nicht
lockerungen erfolgt muss auf akzeptanz
in der bevölkerung stoßen denn nur wenn
die bevölkerung mit macht wenn sie
versteht warum bestimmte freiheits
einschränkungen erforderlich sind
dann sind wir auch erfolgreich wir
können das nicht durch kontrolle
letztlich nach vorne bringen seine die
menschen müssen das verstehen ist und
sie müssen es akzeptieren das ist die
zentrale voraussetzung deswegen erinnern
wir natürlich da man das immer gesagt
habe wenn wir einen hohen im schutze der
bevölkerung haben und damit vermeiden
können dass unser gesundheitswesen
überlastet wird und insofern versorgung
vielleicht nicht mehr möglich sein wird
für schwerkranke dann stehen lockerungen
an und im moment sind wir in dieser
situation wir haben einen hohen schutz
gerade bei den gefährdeten
bevölkerungsgruppen
deshalb ist die erwartung in der
bevölkerung natürlich auch da dass die
politik jetzt diesen ankündigungen auch
taten folgen lässt vergaß ganz
herzlichen dank dass sie sich heute
morgen für uns zeit genommen haben recht
herzlichen dank an danke und wir machen
nun direkt weiter denn wer wurde in
dieser pandemie am häufigsten befragt
virologen und da möchten wir jetzt zu
klaus stöhr schalten hast du auch sie
haben eine ganz klare forderung wie
verhindern wir jetzt den nächsten job
down ja also wenn ich da eine ganz klare
idee hätte dann vielleicht bin ich dann
anwärter für nobelpreis ich glaube so
etwas sollte wirklich die expertengruppe
entscheiden die die bundesregierung
sichert euch jetzt sofort und schnell
einberufen wird
ein interdisziplinäres team was über die
länder und grenzen hinausgeht da die
bundesländergrenzen der fast vom bund
koordiniert wird wo kollegen aus den
verschiedensten fachdisziplinen arbeiten
die sich jetzt vorausschauend überlegen
was man machen muss als plan für den
übergang zur normalität der muss jetzt
auf den tisch einschließlich welche
maßnahmen man auf die ergreifen muss um
auf die unausweichliche heftige winter
welle zu reagieren und vor allem die
neue locker und zu verhindern und
schulschließungen und nach gut ist es
jetzt insbesondere den schutz der
hochrisiko person in einem pflegeheim
vor
zu breit dafür habe ich natürlich auch
ideen ich habe das sind die dinge die
gemacht werden muss aber die umsetzung
dafür braucht man wirklich ein
multidisziplinäres team fragen sie da
nicht den biologen der wird dann
vielleicht sagen ja wir haben drei neue
aminosäuren auf dem wir müssen alles zu
machen fragen auch nicht den
intensivmediziner oder den npd meldung
allein sondern die bundesregierung muss
hier wirklich ein multidisziplinäres
experten team einberufen das die dann
berät mit alternativvorschlägen wir
haben ja alle natürlich keine
kristallkugel
wir wissen nicht genau wie im herbst
sich die situation entwickeln wird aber
darauf kann man sich vorbereiten indem
man alternativen entwickelt die vor
nachteile klar aufzeichnet die parameter
beschreibt mit denen man dann die
situation einschätzen wird und dann die
maßnahmen zu den entsprechenden
parametern dazu gibt ideen haben wir ja
einen ganz einfachen klaren ja schon mal
gezeigt wie sagen wir machen am ersten
oktober auf weil er ins elend über 500
in den gemeinden oder über 1000 in den
städten müssen wir uns noch mal neue
maßnahmen ergreifen aber bis dahin wird
jetzt sicherlich die der plan seien am
ersten oktober bis das traktor alles
aufzuheben nach fängt man schon im
august an
es stört wenn sie jetzt das sehen auch
dieses papier was wir gestern bei bild
als erstes veröffentlicht haben haben
sie das ein bisschen ein déjà vu auch
die formulierung die dort stehen das
erinnert ja alles daran als werden wir
sozusagen noch in der schlimmsten phase
der pandemie oder ja irgendwie finde ich
dass wir uns in kleinen
paralleluniversum bewegen in deutschland
auch für die anderen länder vergleicht
ich meine england hat natürlich
sicherlich radikalen schritt getan
meines erachtens ein bisschen früh man
hat noch nicht alle impfangebot gemacht
aber die normalität müssen wir jetzt ins
auge fassen wir können ja nicht ewig an
denen anja der konservativen pandemie
planung hängen bleiben wenn es überhaupt
eine planung grad aber die impfrate ist
jetzt ja hoch
neben einigen ländern jetzt über die
impfung über 90 prozent schon ist das
wirklich die situation sich beruhigt
dass die intendanten sich abkoppeln von
den sterberaten und jetzt muss wirklich
was passieren dass das mal die realität
ins auge fasst das heißt natürlich nicht
dass man jetzt alle maßnahmen kritiklos
sofort aufhört sondern dass man sich
genau überlegt
was macht man im herbst wenn die
unausweichliche winter welle zunimmt die
kinder sind zum großteil hat noch nicht
immun das ist anders als bei den anderen
endemischen infektionserkrankung gibt ja
über 200 atemwegserkrankungen und gibt
es bis zum alter von zwölf der 17 18
jahren je nach erreger und je nach land
werden dann stufenweise alle kinder
sukzessive mit dem erreger in kontakt
kommen oder baut sich so eine so einen
immunschutz auf dass dabei der
qualifikation noch nicht passieren er
stelle noch mal ganz kurz werden am
sonntag die auch eine heftige diskussion
genau zu der frage unter anderem mit der
blume und herrn gassen wann glauben sie
erleben wir hier in deutschland den
freiheitstag den ist in großbritannien
schon gab und in das am ersten oktober
auch in dänemark geben soll
also wenn sie mich fragen sollte der
dann kommen wenn alle in ein impfangebot
gemacht wurde und das ist jetzt
interessant nach dem papier was die
bundesregierung vorgestellt hat dem
entwurf steht drin wort wirklich das nun
schon alle nein im angebot gemacht
werden konnte also rein rechtlich glaube
ich ich bin kein anwalt müsste man jetzt
überlegen kann man denn überhaupt noch
diese maßnahme aufrechterhalten und im
letzten paragraf steht ja auch dass man
jetzt diese besondere geologische lage
wieder verlängern will aber das passt
irgendwie alles inhaltlich nicht
zusammen
ich glaube jetzt muss man wirklich an
die konkreten schritte denken jetzt kann
ja nicht so sein dass man mit den
instanzen die wir jetzt haben relativ
hoch 30 40 50
bei den 20 bis 30 jährigen und sehr
gering bei den hochrisikogruppen dass
man damit so weitermachen kann wie
bisher
ansonsten würde man ja ewig eigentlich
in dem lokal bleiben
das sagte virologe klaus stöhr vielen
dank an sie für diese einschätzungen die
sie uns gegeben haben wir sind bild und
wir liefern dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren